We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2 1 9 2.
David P..
I've gotten a lot of messages lately from
people asking what happened to the egg man?
Is the egg man dead?
Why haven't we heard from the egg, man?
Because I'm trying to introduce a little levity
into the voicemail segment, because a lot
of the news lately is not not very positive.
I have an example today of why we are not
hearing from the egg man for whatever reason.
For the last several months, every voicemail
that the egg man leaves, the egg man is a
former federal prisoner who lives in upstate
New York and is just a nice guy.
And he was he he was in prison on some drug
charges.
And he's a good guy.
He's a good dog owner.
He's a good father.
All of that stuff anyway.
We've been hearing from him for years, for
some reason months ago, every time the egg
man calls and it sounds like he's under water.
And I just can't play the voicemails for you
because we can't understand a word he's saying.
I will play one for you and you will see exactly
what I mean.
Take a listen to this.
Governor Cuomo.
Cuomo.
Wow.
Or whatever.
OK.
I think you guys get the idea.
I'm picking up some words.
CUOMO Alex Jones, essential.
Is he standing 50 feet from his phone?
Is he in some kind of bunker?
I don't know what is going on with Eggman,
but we can't.
This is not the phone quality that our viewers
have come to expect.
I wonder how many are hiring lawfirm?
OK, I understood that.
How many businesses are highly hiring law
firms to claim that they are now essential
businesses?
So anyway, Eggman is very much alive.
He's still calling in.
But Eggman.
You've got to fix your phone.
Please, please, please do something there
so we can we can hear you better.
OK.
On the bonus show today, it turns out that
Obama administration officials did a tried
to do a training with Trump aides about how
to handle a global pandemic.
This was an exercise back in 2017.
Turns out they didn't learn much.
Many of them just didn't attend.
We also have learned that there are starting
to be prisoner releases of nonviolent prisoners
because of the virus threat.
We are going to explore how Ohio is managing
it.
And look at whether this might be adopted
in other states.
And then lastly, when we talk about priorities,
legislative priorities, often Idaho is very
backwards.
And Idaho has not passed anything related
to the virus.
But in the last week, they have passed two
anti transgender bills.
Priorities, right?
Priorities.
Make sure you join me on today's bonus show.
Get instant access by becoming a member at
Join Packman dot com or becoming a patron
at Patry on dot com slash David Patkin show.
Not only do you get instant access to the
bonus show, you also get a commercial free
audio and video feed of the show every single
day.
I'll talk to you.
I'll talk to them.
David Packman show at David Pacman dot com.